nearly 18 million people watched his
bittersweet swan song on NCIS last night
now it's on to his new project which
will air right after NCIS at the fall
right after NCIS the coveted times up we
all know that this is a blessing and I
we take it very seriously I mean we all
jumped up and down and got excited but
then we then we took it really seriously
in bull Weatherly plays a trial
consultant based on dr. Phil that's
right before he was this guy what are
you a Stepford wife
McGraw worked in the legal field helping
defendants Weatherly has dr. Phil's
hardball demeanor down I do know you're
lying about something did any part of
his betrayal surprise you
he's got a really kind of smart ellika
attitude when he needs to have it okay
so we have a defendant going in front of
a conservative judge with a boy band
haircut and pimp sneakers dr. Phil is
executive producer of the drama he also
co-wrote the pilot this is not
biographical because he breaks a lot of
laws that I do